marc fesneau ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement est l'invité
d'auditions publiques bonsoir et merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté l'invitation
des chaînes parlementaires de la fp et
du figaro le chat du figaro est ouvert
bien sûr pour les internautes qui
peuvent réagir poser leurs questions
comme chaque semaine je me fais votre
relais bien sûr sur ce plateau trois
séquences bien sûr pour vous marquez no1
comme chaque semaine mes confrères
jérémy marot et vincent roux sont déjà
là messieurs bonsoir
mais quand soeur brigitte boucher oriane
mancini seront là tout à l'heure et
entre les deux la séquence des
parlementaires avec le sénateur et l'ère
roger karoutchi et le député socialiste
luc carvounas qui viendront vous
interpeller tout à l'heure dans une
vingtaine de minutes mark snow vous êtes
un euro enthousiaste oui oui bien sûr et
bien l'europe ce soir est encalminée
comme jamais emmanuel macron d'ailleurs
reconnaît en termes assez cru l'échec
des chefs d'état et de gouvernement à
désigner leurs plus hauts responsables
alors c'est aussi son échec mais il
incrimine sur tous les autres quelle
image ce soir de l'europe division
incapacité de s'entendre oui c'est
l'image que l'europe a donné depuis des
années espérons qu'il sortira de cette
séquence des dirigeants qui permette de
sortir de cette ornière l'adere le
président de la république l'a dit à la
sortie de ce conseil extraordinaire la
nécessité peut-être de revoir les modes
de désignation dans l'avenir il a
exprimé sa colère mais est-ce que la
colère est bonne conseil devrait enfin
il a fait avec ses mots non mais
manifestement c'est vrai qu'on n'était
pas loin manifestement dans la nuit d'un
accord est un groupe de pays a décidé
d'empêcher cet accord est donc il faut
remettre le l'ouvragé sur le métier et
donc il ya quelque chose d'assez
désagréable dans ce moment où l'europe
cela du mal à sortir à chaque fois de la
lune crise de nerfs dès qu'il s'agit de
prendre des décisions importantes
ils seraient comme bon que dans les
années qui viennent on arrive à prendre
des décisions sans qu'on soit chaque
fois dans le psychodrame convient ça
prouve que 28 on a déjà du monde du mal
à prendre des décisions et qu'il faudra
trouver des mécanismes qui pourraient me
permettre de prendre des décisions
autrement parce que là on est dans
devant les citoyens européens il ya
quelque chose qui est assez désagréable
des sentiments qu'il ya des urgences d
urgence climatique d'hergé tu veux pas
voir d urgence économique et que l'on
passe son temps à essayer de trouver des
équilibres complexe mais précisément
marc fesneau avant peut-être de revoir
les modes de désignation des process de
désignation est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
mode de désignation qui tout simple qui
est de suivre la volonté des peuples
apparemment c'est la droite qui est
sorti vainqueur au niveau européen de ce
scrutin et il y avait un candidat qui
étaient les verts et si on avait suivi
le scrutin le leçons du scrutin s'il y
avait un candidat naturel c'est ce qu'on
appelle le speedcell candidate jeté par
la france oui mais pardon de vous dire
qu'avec de +35 pardon de vous dire
depuis 35 ans que c'est la première fois
que ppe parti populaire européen droite
+ ps ne font pas la majorité au
parlement européen il s'est passé
quelque chose de nouveau parlement
européen
c'est l'émergence d'une force centrale
et donc on peut pas à l'avance présenter
ce que doit être le candidat de la
commission européenne sans tenir compte
du résultat des urnes mais qu'est ce
qu'on a voulu faire ce sommet européen
et avec d'autres pays c'est lui dire il
ya les hurons parler aussi
c'est pas parce que le ppe est en tête
que pour autant le ppe est à lui seul
majoritaire et donc il ya besoin de
trouver des compromis avec le ppe avec
le pse avec la force que nous avons
contre centrale que nous avons pu
construire au parlement européen avec
les écologistes et donc a besoin de
trouver un compromis qui permette de
tenir compte du vote parce que si il
suffit simplement d'être en tête à 15 ou
20 % pour considérer qu'à soi seul on
peut diriger le parlement européen et
donc les institutions européennes par
ailleurs moi je pense qu'il ya une
erreur démocratique donc c'est les urnes
ont parlé les minorités de blocage qui
doivent nous excuser moi c'est une
majorité de blocage parce que jusqu à
nouvel an le ppe tout seul n'a pas la
majorité et le ps les écologistes et les
autres non plus donc il faut trouver un
compromis et donc le compromis ce n'est
pas d'arriver avec son candidat et de
dire je pense que je suis arrivé en tête
même loin de la majorité j'ai le droit à
mon candidat c'est comme ça que ça se
passe je pense que c'est une bonne
pratique démocratique même si c'est une
logique de coalition un logique
classique de coalition sauf qu'on a
rompu aux coalitions qui était en place
et qui est un produit cet échec était la
coalition du ppe et du pse et donc c'est
bien qu'on a on ait pu rendre cette
coalition avec les centristes et avec
les écologistes
jérémy
autre décision qui semble avoir été
prise en catimini tout du moins derrière
des portes closes c'est l'accord passé
avec le mercosur
cet accord commercial qui suscite la
controverse en réalité à part emmanuel
macron qu'il a jugés plutôt bons
on voit pas qui est pour y compris au
sein de la majorité où des points de
vigilance plus ou moins exacerbée
s'exprime alors selon vous est-ce que
cet accord est un bon accord
d'abord la difficulté de ces accords
internationaux et celui là ne fait pas
défaut --même est exemplaire au mauvais
sens du terme ces désaccords où on lance
une négociation c'était 18 ans il ya
vingt ans sur le mercosur
on donne un mandat de négociation la
commission européenne qui est la seule
compétente faute comme dire des choses
comme elles surpassent qui est la seule
compétente a mené les négociations une
fois que le mandat et est donné par les
chefs de gouvernement il ya 18 ou 20 ans
ça n'était pas ce gouvernement
reconnaissant le deuxième élément on a
un accord qui alors la difficulté
démocratique du coup n'est parce que
pendant vingt ans il se passe rien ou 18
ans et se passe rien puis tout d'un coup
au détour d'un vendredi ou d'un samedi
on dit tiens le mercosur et les
négociateurs européens sont arrivés à un
accord il ya un sujet ce côté la
commission finissante vous avez raison
par ailleurs après le scrutin
oui mais c'est le jeu je pense pas que
ce soit forcément extrêmement ces mois
après qu'un homme a pris après le
processus pardonnez moi parce qu'il faut
respecter les éléments démocratique je
redirai ce que je voulais dire après
mais c'est qu'après le parlement
européen est saisie de l'accord et le
parlement européen il est en droit et en
légitimité de l'accepter de le rejeter
et de dire qu'il faut revenir un mandat
de 18 ans
doit-elle leur vitesse mais il faut
alors qui d'autre d'entre nous autour de
la table à cet accord personne donc on
va regarder l'accord je pense qu'il faut
regarder les causes qui sont donc en
particulier à deux sujets qui me
paraissent nécessité d'une grande
vigilance et le sujet agricole et
deuxièmement c'est le sujet climatique
c'est en quoi le sujet l'accord permet
d'avancer sur le sujet climatique et sur
ce sujet de la biodiversité en
particulier avec le brésil sur la
question de la déforestation
on verra ce qu a marqué dedans et 2
est-ce que ça déséquilibre trop au
niveau agricole notamment sur la viande
bovine puisque c'est le sujet essentiel
les choses empiraient
élément quand même de compréhension
puisque effectivement dans cet accord on
découvre que et bien l'europe l'amérique
latine va pouvoir exporter cent mille
tonnes de boeuf
donc on prend on comprend la colère et
l'angoissé l'inquiétude des éleveurs en
europe écologie sont pas sont alors
pardonnez moi personne ne le découvre
totalement puisque c'était la crainte
non mais moi j'ai discuté avec les fuit
la filière viande bovine au salon de
l'agriculture c'est au mois de février
il avait une crainte sur le mercosur sur
les capacités d'exportation qu'ont donné
au mercosur et c'est pas le ministre de
l'agriculture didier guillaume s'est
insurgé il ya quelques mois c'était au
mois de mars et pour à l'assemblée
nationale contre cette perspective si
simplement respecter le processus
comment peut-on parler un mot nation les
négociateurs européens
je me rappelle il ya un certain nombre
d'années c'était en 92 des accords du
gatt qui avait produit des tas de
manifestations des accords en
particulier sur le volet agricole qui
s'était passé quand aussi une fois
l'accord regarder et les conséquences de
l'accord regardez il ya vu une
renégociation de l'accord donc il faut
regarder la corde qu'est ce qu'il a de
positif
qu'est-ce qui est la négative vous ne
trouverez pas en moi chez moi quelqu'un
qui soit un protectionniste échevelé
parce que le protectionnisme
on sait où ça mène d'un point de vue
économique il ya aussi des bons accords
il ya des bons accords qui ont été faits
en particulier sur la viande bovine avec
le japon donc il faudrait aussi citer
les bons accords économiques est ce
qu'on est là dans le cadre de l'europe
qui protège est ce que c'est je le rends
c'est ça l'europe 10 ses effectifs sont
énormes et je connais un peu ce secteur
et par ailleurs je suis dans un
département agricole pour nous
préoccuper mais en soi d'ailleurs mais
j'entends tout à fait la colère je dis
qu'il faut regarder cet accord et
devient deuxième sujet qui est un sujet
de fond d'ailleurs me semble-t-il qui a
été levé alors même si je ne partage pas
tout à fait la façon dont nicolas hulot
l'a évoqué qui est la question de à quoi
servent les accords commerciaux est ce
qu ils peuvent être un outil puissant
pour engager des pays vert en
particulier la transition économique
assure nicolas hulot dit que c'est en
tunisie il faut
non mais nicolas hulot dit en gros les
accords de libre échange il faut
renoncer aux accords de libre échange
parce que par nature le libre échange
il est anti écologique jean de toutes
les problématiques et si nous y mets moi
les silos lol
si ce que nous proposons au monde c'est
le retour aux frontières et de
protectionnisme
il faut expliquer le modèle économique
dans lequel on vivra donc et donc faut
faire là bas il faut laisser à la maison
j'ai dansé un discours que le discours
vous tenez ce discours contient depuis
les accords du gatt justement 1994
dès qu'il ya le mot protection qui est
donné on a l'impression en amont non
obscènes et donc c'est ce libre est
gentil et qui a réussi à se développer
et si aujourd'hui dénoncés par des gens
qui nicolas hulot et si le monde n'était
pas en blanc noir et que nous pouvions
une puissions à la fois échangé et en
même temps donner dans les échanges des
contraintes en particulier
environnementale qui disent moi je ne
discuterai le président de la république
a refusé d'engager les négociations avec
les états unis sur ce motif la l'accord
du mercosur pose ces questions là le
parlement européen va s'en saisir
maintenant qu'il est sur la table
j'imagine que les parlementaires
européens qui siègeront à partir de
demain vont le regarder avec grande
attention et à partir de là on on
prendra nos options
le gouvernement français et le parlement
européen mais par nature dire qu'un
accord est forcément mauvais je ne
refuse de fermer par nature dire qu'un
accord est forcément bon aussi donc il
faut les regarder d'un point de vue
pragmatique mais si nous pouvions faire
de ces accords internationaux
une voix pour engager le maximum de pays
vers la transition écologique et donc la
transition économique et donc regarder
les échanges
à la lumière de l'ordre leurs effets
climatiques leurs effets sur la
biodiversité moi je pense qu'on
simplement qu'ils vont nous regarder
quand même cet accord avec des lunettes
roses
excusez moi non je ne sens pas l'avoir
regardé je voudrais le regardais tout
court si vous êtes intéressé qui à cet
accord dans le massif qui aujourd'hui à
cet accord dans les mains conseillé par
exporter plus j'ai du mal à parler de
choses que je n'ai pas sous les yeux
d'accord merci c'est que c'est dans un
monde où c'est c'est toujours commode de
parler de ce qu'on a pas sous les yeux
mais le brésil mais j'aimerais avoir cet
accord d'accord regardez là des éléments
nous ont réagi sur les éléments qui nous
ont été communiqués si j'aurai un accord
historique tant qu'on a regardé on nous
a proposé la commission dit des choses
il ya un parlement européen qui
chargeaient de ratifier parfois souvent
même les parlement nationaux chargés de
ratifier et donc on regarde je reviens
pas sur votre commentaire enfin pour
l'instant votre attentisme d'une
certaine manière comme si vous incitez
le
le brésil particulièrement à produire
plus de viande bovine à l'exporter c'est
un mauvais signe pour la déforestation
de l'amazonie dont on a tant besoin
antinomique de nicolas hulot semble
approprié je pense que le problème avec
le brésil n'est pas tant sur la question
de il est sur le volume de viande bovine
mais la déforestation délit plutôt à la
transformation pour faire du soja
c'est pas pour faire trop d'aidé des
bovins donc la question c'est plutôt le
soja la question ces cultures pour faire
du pour faire du carburant dit
écologique
il n'est pas du tout parce que quand
vous déforester vous faites vous dédiez
la terre à des cultures qui ne font que
du carburant il ya un problème au delà
l'écologie un problème éthique donc
c'est plutôt sale pas la question des
bovins est une question de déséquilibre
ou non avec nos filières ssao faisons
oui enfin on est capable quand même
c'est les sujets qui a vu sur d'autres
que je sache la sphère du boeuf aux
hormones c'était au début des années 80
on avait interdit de bois faisant mine
depuis lors il n'est pas rentré de bois
faisant ma direction décide qui a pas de
boeuf aux hormones n'y aura pas de bug
faisant faudra être vigilant sur léoni
fou il faut toujours être vigilant
permettez moi de vous dire même être
vigilant dans les frontières européennes
parce qu'il semble que les récentes
crises sanitaires y compris sur la
viande hachée
elle venait pas de l'extérieur de nos
frontières européennes alors jérémy
encore une question alors que sur un
autre accord autres accords de libre
échange c'est celui sur le ceta le
traité de libre-échange avec le canada
il arrive à l'assemblée le 17 juillet
nicolas hulot appel à s'y opposer
est ce que vous ne craignez pas
justement que cet accord de
libre-échange là le ceta d'un lieu à des
divergences au sein de la majorité qui
se dirait il ne faut pas avoir le style
est en oeuvre depuis deux ans donc
maintenant cette équipe qui est en
application
notez la catastrophe c'est justement en
matière manifestement ce n'est pas la
catastrophe annoncée peu après en
matière d'élevage puisque ils ont tous
complètement saoul consommer les quotas
qui leur est attribué en termes de
gergovie parce que il faut qu'ils
fassent des filières qui correspondent à
nos standards donc mais au-delà de cet
élément plutôt positif vous en discutez
avec les ponts on a pour la première
fois sur le continent américain un
accord qui reconnaît les i gp où les aoc
pour ceux qui voudraient surtout les
appellations d'origine contrôlées dont
qui reconnaissait la spécificité la
qualité et le terroir
bon c'est pas inintéressant qu'on
regarde ça par ailleurs il ya des
éléments puisqu'on est que sur
l'agriculture autour du lait qui était
plutôt positif il ya un sujet sur la
viande bovine
deuxième sujet dans l'accord qui était
en tout cas au questionnement c'est
l'impact climatique ou non et donc ces
éléments là on a demandé
marielle de sarnez qui est présidente de
la commission des affaires étrangères a
demandé avec ses collègues qui puisse y
avoir des éléments tangibles sur le
premier volet le plus inquiétant c'était
le seul d'ailleurs sur le volet viande
bovine et le deuxième sur quelles sont
les conséquences en terme d'impact
écologique et donc les parlementaires
vont en débattre 1100 que cet accord est
d'une autre nature que mercosur c'est un
accord avec des partenaires dont on sait
le chemin sur les calissons j'ai pas
entendu monsieur trudeau remettre en
cause l'accord de paris et donc je pense
qu'on a une nécessité d'entraînement nos
partenaires au travers des accords
commerciaux mais départ tous les
parlementaires dans son saisir et en
débattrons si j'ai bonne mémoire le 17
juillet dans l'actualité qui nous ramène
encore à l'europe il y à la sphère du
seaworld avec l'interpellation en italie
donc de la capitaine de ce bateau
humanitaire qui a forcé les barrages est
ce que paris demande sa libération ce
soir non mais c'est pas paris demandé sa
libération et des process qui
comprendrait le fleuve comment berlin je
ferais mais moi je ne demande pas la
libération mais comment ou soutenons-le
man ou l'italie c'est pas la question ce
cas l'allemagne et l'italie en tout cas
il ya quelque chose qui serait
incompréhensible c'est qu'on emprisonne
quelqu'un qui a au fond porté secours à
des gens qui étaient en train de se
noyer ou qui portait le risque de se
noyer l'obligation de la police
italienne obligations humanitaires
passait pas l'interprétation de la
police italienne peut-être ou de
monsieur salvini sans doute
enfin le nombre de morts qui a eu sur
les côtes au sud de la méditerranée ou
non de la méditerranée plaident pour
l'idée que quand des gens prennent un
canot il porte un risque mortel qui
nécessite quand même que si un bateau
qui croise dédiée ou pas dédié il puisse
porter au secours aux gens et donc on a
une nécessité moi je pense qu'il ya deux
sujets il y avait la question et par
marc fesneau la location c'est plutôt
des organisations humanitaires qui sont
accusés justement d'aller non aulas au
large de
de l'italie des côtes européennes et qui
crée un appel d'air
justement pensé pour ces réfugiés c'est
ce que reproche matteo salvini moi
monsieur
j'ai du mal à penser ça je vous le dis
très simplement je ne crois pas que vous
partiez de chez vous en attendant un
bateau au milieu de la méditerranée où
vous partiez de chez vous parce que ils
vous chanterez de partir de chez la
compagne avoir un effet avolon
christophe que des noms mais je vous
remercie aussi le centre historique
alstom christophe cassiau nerfs mais je
le rôle de sa part je vais emmener comme
ça il à préciser les choses
il a dit il faut faire attention à ce
qu'on n'organise pas des mécanismes qui
donnerait le sentiment qu on facilite
mais là on est sur un bateau qui a
récupéré des gens mer on est bien
d'accord
donc c'est un bal à ou qui illustre
justement ce genre de mécanisme qui a
nominé pour sa part christopher et moi
si nous n'avions pas eu des bateaux
comme ça en méditerranée combien de
morts de plus
c'est ce que vous dites a créé sauf qu'à
ce nom c'est parce que j'ai un
christophe cassiau n'est pas ce que vous
même portant pardonner l'apport
contradiction avec lui par zone et moi
de vous dire que vous pardonnez moi de
vous dire je crois que vous caricaturez
un peu ce qu'a dit christophe castaner
il a dit qu' il pouvait y avoir des cas
où par la façon dont s'était organisé on
pouvait faire un portrait non non non
mais il a explicité d'ailleurs je parle
lors d'une question au gouvernement à
l'assemblée nationale
apprendre à un sujet central et sept
défis d'ailleurs de la commission qui va
être nommé du parlement européen sept
défis migratoires parce qu'il suffit pas
de dire là on est sur 50 réfugiés ici
sur 100 et c'est la question migratoire
et la france ont accueilli une partie de
ses 40 jeux sont pas je ne sais pas ce
qui va se passer en italie une fois
qu'ils sont accostées en italie si j'ai
bien compris ils seront sans doute
accueillie par l'italie enfin je sais
pas mais nous avons déjà pris notre part
n'y a pas de responsabilité parce que
ils étaient prêts à ce que d'autres pays
la vase avons déjà prises de parts dont
on recevra pas de leçons dans ce domaine
et la question n'est pas chaque bateau
qui à cause de rentrer dans ces
polémiques et c'est parce que vous
faites mais je pense qu'il faut qu'on
arrête de sacs de rentrer dans ces
polémiques il faut qu'on trouve des
solutions d'avoir de stabilisation dans
ces pays et deux des solutions pour
accueillir les gens dans des conditions
qui soient acceptables ceux qui ont le
droit au droit d'asile
il faut qu'on les accepte et qu'on les
pistes et répartir entre pays européens
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pourquoi
matteo salvini apparaît sur la scène
italienne
parce que l'égoïsme européens étaient à
l'oeuvre parce qu'on a dit aux italiens
c'est pas de chance pour vous la
méditerranée vous appelez faire la
méditerranée la géographie la tectonique
des plaques a placé l'italie là et donc
quand vous venez du sud de la
méditerranée vous arrivez d'abord en
italie
en grèce vous n'arrivez pas en finlande
cette intervention une angoisse des
italiens également mais oui c'est ce que
je dis c'est qu'on a laissé les italiens
leur disant ils sont arrivés chez vous
maintenant c'est votre problème mais ce
n'est pas le problème que des italiens
c'est le problème du monde entier cette
question là et on a eu ce problème là il
ya 40 ou 50 ans quand il ya eu les boat
people
on était sur des sujets de même nature
et donc la question qui a c'est comme en
exerçant sa solidarité
comment on exerce pleinement le droit
d'asile et quand ça ne relève pas du
droit d'asile comme ont raccompagné la
frontière mais on le fait avec
l'humanité nécessaire et donc le moins
polémique nécessaire et c'est ça que je
pense qu'il faudrait qu'on évite jérémy
marot sans doute été interpellé par ces
images de militants écologistes
dispersés à coup de gaz lacrymogènes
samedi une enquête et paris une enquête
a été confiée à l'igpn est ce que à
titre personnel cette image vous en
jugerez bon que les images et puis
paraître choquant après il ya une
enquête qui est en cours pour pour
expliquer le pourquoi de cette action-là
comme l'a dit la garde des sceaux ce
matin je comprends que s'est hissée
images aient pu paraître choquant les
halles de la france vous a paru de
disproportionnée dans les séries excusez
moi de vous dire vous pouvez avoir des
gens qui bloquent pour lequel usage de
la force et qui s'assoit quelque part et
pour lequel usage de la force nécessaire
et d'autres pour lesquels ça paraisse
moins nécessaire laissons faire
l'enquêté le préfet de police en
retraite
une scène effectivement qui a choqué on
a eu aussi un incident à nantes avec
d'ailleurs la disparition d'un jeune
amateur de musique le soir de la fête
qu'est ce qui se passe il ya un problème
dans la façon dont les ordres sont
délivrés aux forces de l'ordre
ça ne se passe pas capable de vous dire
que depuis 6 ou 12 mois
c'est à dire neuf même les forces de
l'ordre l'ordre sont soumises à rude
épreuve et que tous les week-ends il ya
des tas de manifestations un certain
nombre d'entre elles produisent des
événements violents à chaque fois qu'il
ya eu des incidents le ministre de
l'intérieur a saisi l'igpn la saisie ou
la justice s'est autosaisie d'ailleurs
qu'il y avait des questions laissons
faire la justice que d'accord vous vivez
après les images que jérémy a évoqué
vous vous refusez par exemple de parler
de violences policières et je refuse
parce que quand vous êtes dans des
opérations de maintien de l'ordre
forcément vous êtes dans des opérations
délicates et donc c'est très facile
quand on est comme je le suis autour
d'un plateau aux frais de de dire ce
qu'il faudrait faire
comment gères des gens dans une
situation telle ou telle quand il ya eu
des infractions ou quand des choses des
faits avérés ont montré qu'on n'aurait
pas dû agir de la sorte ça a toujours
été fait moi je fais confiance aux
enquêtes qui sont en cours pour montrer
et faire la lumière je me serais de
confiance à la police au son nom mais
pas la police s'est pas seulement
maintenant mais c'est pas seulement la
police il ya dix gpn évidemment par
nature on a des forces de l'ordre qui je
crois font leur travail dans les
conditions des meilleurs face à des
phénomènes niche c'est pas très nouveau
mais depuis quatre cinq ans n'avait
phénomène hyper violent on avait
d'ailleurs commencé à découvrir un
moment de notre dame des landes ont
rappelé de la police fait son travail et
par ailleurs s'il ya besoin il ya des
emplois qui sont faites par la police ou
pour la vie qui derniers mois un tout
petit mot si vous le voulez bien sur le
dossier corse edouard philippe se rend
mercredi le jeudi à bastia ajaccio pour
tenter de renouer le dialogue avec les
élus nationalistes ce dialogue semble
rompu les élus nationalistes on ne sait
pas encore s'ils vont rencontrer le
premier ministre est ce que vous les
appelez justement à se rendre à quand on
veut dialoguer moi je pense que nous
c'est de se rendre
et ont-ils raison de dénoncer un manque
de dialogue mais le jeu de l'or mais je
pense que quand vous êtes là aussi quand
vous êtes dans un dialogue avec une
collectivité en l'occurrence la
collectivité corse et un certain nombre
d'avancées qui ont été produites de
propositions qui ont été faites et donc
on a besoin de dialoguer d'essayer
d'avancer sur un certain nombre de
sujets dans un certain nombre de gens
qui sont plutôt sur des thèses assez
nationaliste et on a le droit de ne pas
les partager et mais c'est pas parce
qu'on ne partage pas les mêmes points de
vue qu'on peut pas dialoguer je pense
que dès qu'on rende dialogue on fait des
fois la démocratie et moi j'invite les
corses j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec les
députés moment la révision
constitutionnelle à renouer le dialogue
parce que le statu quo n'est bon pour
personne et donc si les corses pourrait
aussi sortir de ce set et aulas ça
serait une bonne chose je pense
merci messieurs vous allez laisser votre
place à deux parlementaires de
l'opposition justement pour poursuivre
le dialogue avec nos projets karoutchi à
luc carvounas tout de suite
messieurs bonsoir installez-vous roger
karoutchi sénateur et l'ère des
hauts-de-seine et luc carvounas député
socialiste du val-de-marne où la
question d'une internautes du figaro
marc fesneau
elle s'appelle julia elle parle de
l'encadrement des loyers qui entre en
application aujourd'hui à paris c'est
dans le cadre de la loi de normandie qui
l'a rétablie elle considère elle que
c'est une confiscation de la propriété
privée quand pensez vous d'un mot voilà
pour la propriété privée c'est pas le
droit du travail c'est une
expérimentation
ça a déjà été expérimenté après il
faudra regarder c'est une
expérimentation pour 24 mois autant que
je me souvienne et donc il faudra
regarder l'effet que ça peut produire
dans une grille de paris où on voit que
l'augmentation des loyers chasse un
certain nombre de gens de la radio que
ça parce que on nous raconter ce matin
dans le figaro économique en fait
emmanuel macron ne crois pas du tout
cette mesure non pas parce que c'est une
atteinte à la propriété privée mais il
estime qu'il ya des effets pervers
ça va raréfier justement les logements
sur le marché puisque les propriétaires
ils vont plus loin mais c'est ça qu'il
faudra regarder mais je pense qu'on
n'est pas dans le même dispositif que
celui qui avait été imaginé par cécile
duflot tendre et vienne on est dans un
dispositif qui est d'une autre nature il
faut expérimenter essayons et regardons
l'idée c'était de regarder à paris quel
effet ça pouvait produire
regardons d'accord roger karoutchi et du
cameroun à ce soir donc le soir elle et
qui ouvrent le feu monsieur karoutchi
moi tiens monsieur le ministre
la démocratie est fragile partout en
europe et en france comme ailleurs est
ce que vous croyez sincèrement que jouer
le veto présidentiel sur ces le rn
marine le pen ou moi ça suffit est ce
que le quasi refus de considérer qu'il
ya une vie publique politique des partis
un parlement et que tout se joue déjà
sur un pré deuxième tour de
présidentielle
est ce que c'est le respect de la
démocratie est ce que c'est pas
dangereux parce que ça voudrait dire que
si si emmanuel macron ne réussissait pas
la seule solution serait marine le pen
est ce que vous n'êtes pas en train
involontairement pas vous perso mais
involontairement de mettre en place un
système complètement fou où on dirait
si nous échouons c'est marine le pen et
tout le reste ne peut pas donner vie à
une alternative est ce que ce n'est pas
extrêmement dangereux pour la démocratie
parce que des organes d salvini il y en
a eu
pourquoi pas en france le moins
important que vous employez d'ailleurs
dans votre propos et je partage un
certain monsieur je vais revenir c'est
le moins volontairement ce n'est pas
nous qui avons décidé de mettre madame
le pen et monsieur mélenchon d'ailleurs
je vous rappelle le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle madame le pen
22 ou 23 monsieur mélenchon en vain donc
les choses comme je les 9 et 10 novembre
donc 45 % des français ont voté pour
ils sont à distinguer l'un et l'autre
enfin pour des partis qui sont plutôt à
passer chez les populistes ce n'est pas
moi que c'est ça préexistait à
l'élection d' emmanuel macron si elle 45
% des gens qui ont voté pour eux c'est
que sans doute et je sais gré afin
personne puisque après tout il faut être
vous me connaissez faut être plutôt
modeste dans ces exercices là on est
dans un monde qui est extrêmement
fracturé et un monde où les populistes
prospère assez facilement une stratégie
politique et pardonnez moi il n'y a pas
de stratégie en tant que tel mais en
tout cas dans y'a pas besoin que nous
ayons une stratégie en tant que tel
puisque dans tous les pays du monde et
en europe particulièrement vous l'avais
dit il ya cette tentation populiste
cette tentation du repli cette tentation
du rejet de l'autre pour des raisons
diverses et variées et souvent par
l'incapacité qu'ont eue les politiques
et une greffe jeune jett grief à
personne parce que c'est un phénomène
historique à répondre au quotidien des
gens on a parlé tout à fait un tout à
l'heure des affaires de mondialisation
on a vendu à des gens la mondialisation
heureuse et ils ont découvert que la
mondialisation n'était pas toujours
heureuses ils ont découvert que
l'industrie disparaisse et que les
territoires pourraient perdre tel ou tel
service ou tel est l activité et donc
notre responsabilité
pas de mettre en scène madame le pen
figure et de vous le président de la
république comme tout la majorité après
tout qui est une opposition qui ne
pourraient y sont républicaines et une
opposition structurée c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle
reconnaissons aussi qu'il serait bon
parfois quand je dire ça de faire en
sorte que l'opposition ne court pas
après les populistes pas vous là non
plus c'est pas super adressez vous aux
gens qui sont là quasi pas vous non plus
nommé jeu essayons de dire les choses
avec un peu de recul c'est pas une
question personnelle mais reconnaissons
que
la course qui ont eu un certain nombre
c'est ce qui s'est passé en italie mais
je vais à lesconil a fini par recourir
après monsieur sa vigne qu'est-ce qui
est sorti c'est monsieur cette ville
c'est ce qui sépare les dacquois est
donc sauf que pour vous la laissez
reconnaissez quand même qu'au moment des
européennes
d'ailleurs marine le pen joué très bien
c'était vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec
monsieur macron voté pour moi et macro
enfin macron ses candidats c'est un
scandale et ses candidats disait c'est
elle ou moi juste pour me permettre de
corriger
monsieur le ministre c'est matteo renzi
qui est amenée matteo salvini matteo
renzi qui est très similaire dans la
pratique du pouvoir du président actuel
politique très néo libérale et qui a
apporté dans cette confrontation
l'extrême droite au pouvoir
en tous les cas moi je m'inscris pas
dans cette dans ce match que l'on a
voulu installer vous dites que vous ne
saisissez le président de la république
qui l'a installé à l'étranger dans unis
dans une conférence de presse
un président de la république français à
l'étranger sur un seul qui n'est pas le
seul national qui dit tout de go je vais
mettre toute mon énergie pour battre
marine le pen est hilare un stage et
peut pas de chance pour lui il a perdu
aux élections européennes mais ce que je
vais bien qu'avec la république en
marche on fasse comme si les élections
européennes ont été gagnés par vous non
vous allez je crois bien entendu il est
extrêmement ce soit extrêmement grave en
tous les cas moi je préfère me réjouir
de ce qui s'est passé hier dimanche
c'était les élections partielles du
canton de lodève où le parti socialiste
arrive en tête et 42%
donc quand il s'agit d'avoir des élus
crantée dans les territoires dans les
élections locales
une élection chasse l'autre nous verrons
bien ce qui se passera à l'occasion du
clasico principal je vous faire de
réponse la première c je veux bien qu'on
soit paré de tous les défauts de la
terre mais n'ont pas tous avec le avec
la blague mise à part le premier tour de
la présidentielle de 2017 c'est le bilan
d' qui bat ça c'est évident peut-être de
monsieur hollande en partie 45 % de gens
qui votent chez les pompiers fait son
secrétaire général a réalisé ce nom mais
chercher les responsabilités sont
étonnés non mais le président
le président françois hollande du mal à
prononcer le président là et pour la
petite histoire parce que je vous m'avez
vu plutôt modeste sur les élections
européennes soyez aussi modeste sur
l'élection de lodève
la candidate qui a été qu'est devenu
député européen était socialiste elle
était passée en marge duquel avait été
élu sous l'étiquette socialiste c'est
une sociologique est plutôt socialiste
et l'ancrage territorial sa guise mais
n'en faites pas comment dirais-je
c'est la chute je suis pas sûr que non
j'ai failli en faire on a rien dit que
veut dire monsieur le ministre c'est que
tu accordes dix dates peut passer en
marche la semaine prochaine
écoutez moi j'ai été invité à participer
à cette émission je n'avais pas prévu
que ce soit le 1er juillet c'est une
date qui est extrêmement symbolique
puisqu'il y a un nom simone veil son
mari rentrer au panthéon à l'initiative
du président de la république
tout le monde avait pu s'en féliciter il
se trouve que aujourd'hui j'ai déposé un
projet de loi pour un projet de
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
pour inscrire dans la constitution ce
droit fondamental qui élit léger
pourquoi je fais ça en proposant de
créer un article 66 2 qui serait un
article qu'il succéderait à celui qui à
l'initiative de jacques chirac faisait
entrer dans la constitution
l'idée que nous nous pouvons recourir à
la peine de mort en faisant en sorte que
quels que soient les gouvernements qui
suivait on puisse préserver ses idées
cet acte politique fort donc aujourd'hui
quasi totalité de la gauche
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale a
signé ma proposition de loi est ce que
monsieur demi je connais que tu es très
progressiste vous savez comme moi qu'en
disant 130 centres qui pratiquent les
jets ont fermé vous savez comme moi que
y compris le président du syndicat des
gynécologues a dit récemment que
pratiquer les ivg revenez affaire à un
homicide
est ce que vous êtes d'accord c'est une
question simple ces auditions publiques
monsieur le ministre de nous accompagner
la gauche à l'assemblée nationale au
travers de ma proposition de loi
lorsqu'elle sera discutée à l'assemblée
j'espère très vite j'aurais pas à
rebondir sur le mou dubitative de
monsieur karoutchi mais je vais vous
faire de réponse la première je crois
que le conseil le conseil
constitutionnel
je crois dans une décision de 2001 à
2004 à élever dans sa jurisprudence au
rang constitutionnel le droit à l ivg
personnes dans la classe politique
n'envisage de revenir sur la lune ivg à
ma connaissance aujourd'hui
non mais aujourd'hui ça c'est le premier
sujet donc vous ne jouerez de match 2-1
non mais vous ne trouverez pas chez nous
des gens pour m'aider à cause de chez
vous non plus d'ailleurs
2 je trouve que cette et je le dis sous
l'oeil de monsieur karoutchi qui a russe
qui a réussi une révision
constitutionnelle en 2008
je trouve que la façon que l'on a à
chaque fois qu'on a un sujet ou un
problème ou une question qui pourrait
venir un jour de le mettre à rang
constitutionnel je pense que ce n'est
pas une bonne méthode 7,6 à chaque fois
qu'un sujet pourrait venir ont commencé
le gros fondamentale ali vg est un sujet
non alors mais dont il n'y a pas besoin
de le mettre dans la constitution bien
besoin de marine le pen est présent dans
la revue les deux mains et marine le pen
fera ce qu'elle veut mais il ya le
conseil constitutionnel par la région
rend constitue donc inscrits - le donne
en mille un problème puisque le conseil
considère le mal à blesmes donc ya pas
de problème c'est ça alors essayez de
vous dire bondi sur la provocation
mettre dans la grosse situation
pourquoi le mettre dans la constitution
puis sa cellule et en même temps on est
d'accord je n'ai pas lu votre
proposition parce que je crois vous
l'avait déposée à 18 heures
elle est très simple je vais une ligne
nommée arbres et jeux que vous l'avez
monsieur carvounas je connais le
parcours si on essayait de paccar
écriture et les choses et pas de faire
de la constitution pardonnez moi donc le
droit fondamental à lille et j est un
sujet est une caricature de maintenant
non mais ne cherchez pas traîner car
vous n'y arriverez pas c'était sérieux
j'ai de votre match - de l'oeuvre de
votre machin nom de votre séparation du
jeu à l'achat non mais monsieur
carvounas non mais je vous sens très
gêné non gêné sur quoi sur cette
proposition est gêné de rien je voyais
pas de choses pour la deuxième fois on
va recommencer
avec roger karoutchi car d'autres sujets
constitutionnel question est par
ailleurs les centres divisions fermé pas
pour des raisons de liberté c'est parce
que vous et d'autres au préalable n'ont
pas donné les moyens à ces centres de le
faire donc plutôt que de venir donner
des leçons sur un plateau à vivre y
avait pas d'accord
roger karoutchi d'abord alors d'abord
mon avis là dessus pour une fois je ne
suis pas d'école tout la menace je pense
que dans la bible aussi dangereux mais
c'est bien ça c'est mieux mais on veut
chose c'est mon tour c'est mon tour je
suis le pot limit
alors on vient d'en haut là je dis
seulement que autant moi je suis
favorable ni les gels pour lui ne se
pose pas mais dans la mesure et c'est
pas le seul élément dans la mesure où le
conseil l'a évoqué au niveau
constitutionnel ça veut dire comme tout
état de cause on ne peut pas y toucher
sans l'aval du conseil constitutionnel
il n'y a pas besoin de mettre dans la
constitution comme pour bien d'autres
sujets d'ailleurs alors restons-en là
autres d'accord gc on aura l'occasion
d'en débattre à l'assemblée on en aura
sûrement la corse mais le conseil
conseil pourquoi elle nous non au sénat
sa tournée pas faire n'ont pas d'autres
metteurs ici maciel mines et non par
bouilhou bonne on ne peut pas les sujets
monsieur le ministre vous avez lancé il
ya un an une révision constitutionnelle
on nous a beaucoup parlé d'eux des
modifications d'institutions le
président la république après le grand
débat a fait des grands discours sur la
participation citoyenne settat et
maintenant on nous dira finalement n'a
peut-être pas de révision
constitutionnelle finalement aura
peut-être qu'un texte de loi sur les
modalités d'élection à la
proportionnelle assemblée du nombre de
parlementaires
est ce que vous n'avez pas le sentiment
que la tentative de réformes a échoué
qu'il faudrait peut-être prendre
d'autres d'autres voies pour faire
avancer le débat et en tout état de
cause je dis pas ça parce que je suis
sénateur est ce que croyait pas qu'il
est grand temps de mettre un terme dans
cette espèce de fausse opposition entre
le gouvernement et le sénat comme si le
gouvernement
disait regardez les sénateurs c'est des
méchants et le sénat qui dit et le
gouvernement ne dit pas la vérité et c
est ce qu il faut pas sortir de tout ça
parce qu'après tout les institutions de
la république c'est pour tout le monde
moi même sens que le il ya un an nous
n'en étions pas à ce point là sur la
révision constitutionnelle
les positions étaient plus opposés il me
semble qu'on a cheminé sur deux sujets
on a avancé sur les droits du parlement
s'était d'ailleurs une demande des
sénateurs et une partie de l'opposition
à l'assemblée nationale reconnaissant
ces choses là c'était comme un geste et
puis un deuxième sujet sur lequel on a
annoncé que le président de la
république a évoqué lors de sa
conférence de presse du 25 avril c'était
sur la dose de réduction la réduction de
la réduction du nombre de parlementaires
reconnaissons aussi puisqu'à trois
textes le texte constitutionnel de
textes organiques sais pas pour vous
mais c'est pour que collectivement on
est clair et puis le texte ordinaire qui
pour la proportionnelle
reconnaissons que nous n'avons pas
encore abouti et que le président
larcher à juste titre d'ailleurs a dit
que c'était un tout mais c'est vrai que
c'est un tout puisque c'est une révision
institutionnelle avec plusieurs
séquences que nous n'avons pas encore
abouti sur un certain nombre d'éléments
en particulier la manière de me
représenter au mieux les territoires
avec la réduction qui allait avec moi me
semble que depuis un an on a avancé plus
tôt
et moi je ne déséspère pas qu'on puisse
aboutir sur ces questions là sur la
proportionnelle on est sur un sujet
plutôt assemblée nationale sur la
réduction on est sur un sujet du
parlement lors la manière dont on le
fait et comment on représente les
territoires moi je trouve qu'on a plutôt
avancé que donc vous avez raison de dire
que parfois c'est cet idiot de se
renvoyer la balle entre le sénat et le
gouvernement mais je crois qu'on a
plutôt progressé que les uns les autres
et de l'est pas les uns vers les zones
majoritairement vos textes et pas
regarder le signal parce que d'abord le
sénat a fait un travail souvent
remarquables d'enrichissement des tec de
l'assemblée je dis pas parce que vous
êtes là non mais c'est la vérité dessus
tout mais parce que c'est la vérité oui
bien sûr et que deux mois je trouve
qu'on a toujours rien à gagner en
démocratie quand les deux assemblées se
parle et je pense qu'on a on a plutôt
progressé depuis les gens dans le cgra
le gouvernement parle aux deux
assemblées qu'un gouvernement parle aux
deux assemblées
et preuve en est il ya un certain nombre
de commissions mixtes paritaires ton
petit juif qui sont ces derniers temps
c'est vrai ces derniers temps c'est vrai
moi je pense que dans le champ
démocratique c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle parce que ça permet de garder
l'enrichissement de chacun et d'essayer
de trouver une voie de compromis
c'est plutôt une démocratie car en
sursis
deux jambes on va plutôt dans le bon
sens pour la révision constitutionnelle
allait de nous un peu de temps et
peut-être qu'on pourrait aboutir
institutionnelle puisque c'est
l'ensemble qui est intéressant autre
question l'octogone à ces termes aux
nasa sont là pour à megève et
s'approprier j'avais déjà introduit des
amendements allant dans le sens de ma
position loi mais parce que voilà un
proverbe ena leurs capitales a voté la
révision constitutionnelle chacun 300
civils on ne vous dira pas briques et là
je la laisse surtout ça je suis même
pour le non cumul dans le temps au bout
de deux mandats successifs avec effet
rétroactif dont je suis très à l'aise
mais je ces questions là en tous les cas
je pourrais vous interrogez un pneu sur
adp le référendum d'initiative partagée
mais je veux juste un petit 1,6 parce
que nous sommes des élus franciliens et
nous sommes à 8 9 mois maintenant des
élections municipales moins de deux ans
des missions départementales et
régionales
jacqueline gourault la ministre en
charge des collectivités territoriales
s'est dit plutôt favorable à la mise en
oeuvre du conseiller territorial
peut-être dans le relooking de ce
qu'avait fait le président sarkozy
devant son temps question simple est-ce
que nous allons vers l'élection d'un
conseiller territorial ou est ce moment
où nous nous parlons c'est à dire à
moins de deux ans des chances déchéance
extrêmement importante
la taxe pro foncier bâti et transféré du
département vers les communes pour
transférer la taxe d'habitation donc on
voit qu'on dépouille jacques pour
habiller paul
vers quoi on tend la au niveau
institutionnel et au niveau local
pratico pratiques sur le conseiller
territorial moi je regrette parce que je
pense que c'était à l'époque une bonne
et une bonne idée le conseiller
territorial
la question a été mis sur la table
puisque c'est une partie des réflexions
qu à l gouvernement sur cette question
le conseiller territorial pour des
raisons constitutionnelles je ne veux
pas revenir dedans et une impossibilité
maintenant du fait des 13 régions à
pouvoir activer le principe du
conseiller territorial sauf à avoir une
très grande sous représentation des
territoires les plus ruraux et donc
cette idée
va faire florès elle n'est pas sur la
table d'accord c'est une question qui a
pu se poser mais qui pour des raisons
constitutionnelles ne peut pas se poser
est supposé avoir deux régions mais la
réponse à la corse où il avait évoqué
sur de paris parle beaucoup du creuset
constitutionnel aujourd'hui le conseil
constitutionnel a rendu publics les
chiffres du nombre de signataires 480000
à peu près puisque maintenant le
compteur modestement disparu du site sur
lequel on peut savoir combien de
personnes cliquent le gouvernement a su
trouver 12 millions d'euros pour le
grand débat national en cinq semaines
entre le moment des annonces et le
déroulé du lancement du grand débat
quasiment le même délai pour lancer le
référendum d'initiative partagée
on l'a de 16 dans tous les territoires
d'avoir des retours de bugs y compris le
conseil constitutionnel aujourd'hui qui
a demandé par son communiqué de presse
de ne plus avoir à mettre le code insee
de la ville dans laquelle on vit où on
vote pour améliorer les choses
est ce que monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement compte sur ce plan
démocratique qu'est ce référendum
décisif partager met les moyens puisque
même les spécialistes disent que
l'hébergeur n'est pas suffisamment
conséquent pour accueillir autant de
l'accusé de ses reportages
l'informatique se faire choper le
gouvernement ne met pas les moyens
serait le sens du référendum je crois
qu'il ya des moyens il peut ya pu y
avoir des bugs mais je crois que le
gouvernement met les moyens par ailleurs
ça s'est fait sous le contrôle du
conseil constitutionnel qui n'est pas
avare de dire les choses quand les
choses ne convient de penser la douche
mais il donne des éléments des deux
d'amélioration et c'est bien son rôle en
continu du processus ne dis pas que le
gouvernement sabote le processus est
jeune on met donc à l'arrière parce que
je suis hostile au référendum
je trouve pardon pour une fois que le
conseil constitutionnel n'ait pas dans
la vérité
l'esprit de la réforme de 2008 c'est que
lorsqu'un texte arrive au parlement ce
qui a été le cas pour la privatisation
de la tp eh bien il n'est plus
susceptible d'aller aux références ya un
risque d'affaiblissement du parlement
moi je considère que là il ya un
problème entre la démocratie
représentative la démocratie
participative
le texte a été voté c'est vrai qu'il
n'était pas promulguée
mais je considère que le travail aurait
dû dire c'est contraire à l'esprit de la
constitution
oui sinon c'est la porte ouverte à quoi
bon atout parce qu'il suffira de dire
que tout texte qui arrive au parlement
mais qui n'est pas définitivement
promulguée avec ces décrets peut à tout
moment être remis en cause par le
référendum c'est à dire qu'à tout moment
vous pourrez dire bon mais finalement
aller on recommence enfin au moment où
celui qui écrivait à tous les français
en leur disant nous allons faire un
grand débat national pour vous
questionnez sur tous les sujets dont les
services publics
c'est dans le même temps du grand débat
national kdp la française des jeux ont
été privatisées donc jeté un grand débat
mais je m'assois sur ce qu'on veut dire
merci beaucoup monsieur d'avoir accepté
donc de participer à cet échange avec le
ministre ce soir sur ce plateau merci à
vous vous allez laisser vos places à
brigitte boucher et au rayonnement de
chaîner pour la dernière partie
d'auditions publiques
bonsoir mesdames installez-vous je
découvre la question de quelqu'un qui se
fait appeler sur le site internet du
figaro
je me mêle de ce qui me regarde il vous
demande monsieur le ministre
quelle est donc la définition du mot
populisme que vous avez effectivement
utilisé à plusieurs reprises c'est le
fait de rechercher à chaque fois qu'il
ya des sujets des boucs émissaires et de
chercher dans chez les citoyens que nous
sommes et j'en suis un tout ce qui peut
faire s'affronter les citoyens les uns
contre les autres chercher des boucs
émissaires faciles c'est ça pour moi le
plus c'est de chercher des réponses
simples à des sujets qui sont par nature
complexe et de sous le couvert de
l'appel au peuple de rechercher dans les
sociétés ce qu'il y a de plus replié sur
soi même et donc je pense que c'est un
risque immense première question pour ce
proche du peuple sans être populiste moi
je crois et c'est l'honneur de la
politique que de faire ça auriol on va
parler du parlement puisque aujourd'hui
débute la session extraordinaire session
chargée on va en parler
elle ira jusqu'à fin juillet ce que vous
y voyez plus clair sur la date de
reprise après la pause estivale
on va regarder les choses là parce que
comme je les ai dit tout à l'heure il ya
un certain nombre de commissions mixtes
paritaires conclusive y en a d'autres
qui sont devant nous si elles sont
conclusive elles permettront peut-être
de desserrer un peu de mal andrius de
septembre si elles ne le sont pas après
nous verrons mais nous sommes sur
quelque chose autour de l'horizon de la
deuxième ou de la troisième semaine de
septembre
sachant qu'à partir de l'asie pour
l'assemblée nationale après on verra
pour le sénat aussi donc
et puis vous me permettrez différé ça
peut être une reprise différée ça peut
ne pas l'être
la moindre des corrections en tant que
tel une fois qu'on aura les choses posée
mais ce ne sera pas avant le mois de
juillet c'est d'en parler avec les
présidents des deux assemblées toi c'est
quoi c'est septembre non ça peut être un
peu plus tôt pour l'assemblée nationale
je rappelle qu'on a la session
budgétaire qui commence le 15 octobre et
que donc il ya assez peu de temps entre
le moment budgétaire et la reprise de la
session et la prise de section histoire
d'inr si je peux dire ça doit être
justement un texte emblématique pour
démarrer cette session de septembre
est-ce qu'il faut commencer par la pma
ce que ça pourrait être le gaspillage
belle et si les deux textes que nous
avons sous les yeux puisque le texte sur
les territoires par nature
constitutionnelle
on va d'abord au sénat et donc c'est
l'arbitrage qui sera frais dont elle
sera fait dans l'été qui est passé
encore non mais il sera fait très
prochainement et on dira les choses mais
on voit bien que ces deux textes sur
lequel il faut prendre le temps
particulier je pense à la bioéthique sur
lequel il faut prendre le temps du débat
est donc il faut regarder dans le calage
du calendrier comment les choses se font
pour que le débat sans prendre le temps
en termes de chronologie se fasse dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
après ça sera le rôle des parlements
craignais levée de boucliers a pas eu
une erreur je vois qu'une telle qu'on a
pu progresser de 6 avec grande attention
comme la plupart d'entre nous à faire en
sorte que le débat puisse se dérouler
dans des de manière apaisée qu'ils
soient éclairés aussi par un certain
nombre de comités qui ont donné leur
avis ans au comité d'éthique et d'autre
un travail qui a été fait à l'assemblée
nationale un travail qui a été faussée
match donc je pense que les conditions
sont réunies pour que le débat se passe
de manière certaine que si jean louis
bourlanges un qui est également membre
du modem qui se dit choquée par la
manière dont on traite ce débat vous
n'êtes pas d'accord
moi il me semble que des badauds à ce
stade il n'a pas commencé ce qui
comptera à partir du mois de septembre
ce qui se passe dans les meilleures
conditions il me semble que les termes
qui sont posées aujourd'hui sont des
termes comment dirais-je qui permettent
d'apaiser le débat et je partage pas
forcément le sentiment de jean louis
bourlanges
je peux comprendre les éléments de
tension qu'on peut avoir sur ce texte
après tout c'est l'étape des tickets qui
ne porte pas que sur la question d'un
pma à vrai dire les des questions très
lourde aussi autour de la du droit la
filiation la conservation des ovocytes
la pma post mortem enfin on a des sujets
assez lourd
elles sont devant nous qui nécessite
qu'on le regarde avec calme je pense que
dès lors qu'on trouverait une hache une
architecture deux rapporteurs une
architecture de dialogue entre
l'opposition et la majorité
mais même à l'intérieur de la majorité
et même à l'intérieur des oppositions
ces délices et quand vous on a parlé
tout à l'heure de l'ibg c'est un débat
qui a été comment dirais-je très digne
et à la fois parfois un peu difficile
reconnaissance du temps de simone veil
et qui a permis d'éclairer les uns les
autres
non mais ça parfois été très dur mais en
même temps si monoï apporté avec lui
surtout en apprenant était pourtant
attendu que la voix de ceux qui
n'avaient pas été digne dans le débat on
devrait entendre aussi la voix qui dans
le débat au-delà simone veil qu'il
apportait grande dignité qu'on s'est
comporté avec la plus grande dignité on
a eu le débat sur la loi léonetti pic
laisse leonetti on a pu trouver des
terrains de convergence je crois pas que
ce soit une affaire de l'opposition
d'une majorité c'est pas contraire au
modem au parti chrétien démocrate qui
est très attaché à la famille dit
nucléaire est ce que finalement c'est
pas contraire à vos convictions
moi je ne porte pas comme ça je pense
qu'il ya une logique sur ceux sur la pma
avec une logique de d'ouverture des
droits
reconnaissons aussi qu'il ya un certain
nombre de gens qui pratiquent la pma en
dehors des frontières avec une vaste
hypocrisie dans cette affaire mais dis
donc c'est si c'est pas qu'il ya une
inégalité finalement après situé entre
les femmes et les couples aux hommes
c'est ce qu'a dit jean louis bourlanges
que je cours je partage pas ce sentiment
là et c'est pas parce qu'on est
d'origine démocrate-chrétienne encore
que le modem soit avec beaucoup de
variété en son sein et que vous trouvera
modem des gens qui sont très défenseur
de la pma milliards de livres mais ne
cherchez pas des lignes de division
inutile enfin moi je sais ce que peuvent
être des lignes de division n'y a pas de
lignes de division mais chacun porte
aussi son histoire sa culture ça
conscient ego peut porter librement et
moi je suis tout à fait à l'aise avec
l'idée comme élargissent la pma depuis
toujours évoluer vous même nom depuis
toujours
repetto jour il ya sylviane agacinski à
gauche qui est une voix un peu un peu
différente qui dit qu' on ne peut pas
avoir de droit à l'enfant vous vous
entendez vous ce qu'elle dit et vous le
comprenez c'est pour ça qu'il faut
amener le débat avec cette idée là qu'on
n'est pas et c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs la question de la gp a été
évacué du texte parce que là on va trop
sur le doigt alors un enfant et puis
deuxièmement sur la marchandisation du
corps qui est en principe que tout à
fait refuser en français qu'on a
toujours refusé que qu'on ne compte bien
continuer à refuser mais ne cherchons
pas à imposer l'image écouter ce que dit
sylviane agacinski c'est toujours
intéressant d'avoir l'éclairage de gens
qui pensent et d'autres pensent
différemment d'elle et c'est comme ça
qu'il faudra acheminer pour essayer de
trouver le texte le plus équilibré
il ya la pma pma médical qui existent
aujourd'hui qui permet aux femmes qui ne
peuvent pas avoir d'enfant de pouvoir
procréer et puis à la pma qui sera
sociale est ce que vous trouvez cela
normal qu'elles soient remboursées par
la sécurité sociale
question d'égalité des droits mais oui
ça me paraît pas ça me paraît pas
choquant d'ailleurs le texte prévoit
qu'ils seront remboursés par la sécurité
sociale
oriane très forme la réforme des
retraites alors là aussi plusieurs dates
circulons pour le son examen au
parlement est ce que vous avez une date
plus précise et ce à plusieurs blagues
qui circulent d'une temporalité décembre
après nos débuts 2020 là on attend non
non non mais c'est parce qu on essaye on
l'avait l'avait dit au mois de janvier
aussi s'est il ya une pause dans les
réformes et puis la loi d'orientation
des mobilités la loi sur la fonction
publique
on nous disait vous j'ai l'impression
qu'ils ont interviewé ambitions qu'elle
pose sur les réformes maintenant le
nouveau marronnier de l'été c'est les
retraites à la temporalité est la
suivante elle est assez simple le
haut-commissaire aux retraites va donner
son rapport au mois de juillet
maintenant on va examiner son rapport
parce que le rapport n'est pas la loi
le rapport c'est les grandes
orientations comment on peut faire les
options qui donnera peut-être les
options qui sont retenues par le
gouvernement au pavillon vous permettez
qu'on dise ce temps là quand même
au milieu une petite séquence qui la
séquence budgétaire et donc après il ya
un dialogue qui aura lieu avec les
organisations syndicales c'est bien
normal aussi
au delà du dialogue qui a eu jean paul
delevoye il ya un dialogue une fois que
le texte sera posée oui bien que ça
emmène une temporalité on verra si c'est
décembre verra si c'est un peu plus tard
c'est une réforme pour plusieurs
dizaines d'années est-ce que ce qu'il ya
un lien il ya un moment de
précipitations à voir s'il ya besoin
d'un peu de toi un drap et six épreuves
on verra on verra la tension ne regarde
jamais faire la réforme de la fonction
publique avant les élections européennes
qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a fait la
réforme de la fonction publique avant
les élections européennes
on peut aussi penser qu'on peut sur des
sujets aussi importants que ça les mener
dans le temps qu'on estimera nécessaire
pour que les choses soient pas très bien
alors pour patienter quand même face à
l'urgence des comptes qui se dégrade
on dit que le gouvernement pourrait
accélérer
certains aspects de la réforme touraine
qui a allongé la durée de cotisation
c'est prévu sur plusieurs années est ce
que vous le confirmer ou est ce que
c'est une zone de la thèse écarté nous
sommes dans les éléments de déplacer le
plfss
oui bien sûr j'ai loi de finances par le
biais excusez moi de vous dire je ne
suis ni ministre ni de faire sensation
je comprends tout à fait que je suis
intéressé
on va laisser travailler les ministres
et il nous aura pas échappé que
généralement ce n'est pas le 1er juillet
qu'on rend les arbitrages budgétaires et
donc on regardera les arbitrages
budgétaires
évidemment la question des retraites
c'est une question dès qu'il ya une
question de justice dans la réforme des
retraites il faut faire en sorte que
ceux qui ont des carrières hachées les
femmes d'autres catégories qui ont des
retraites qui sont parfois très faible
puissent converger c'est bien ça
l'objectif de la convergence des régimes
de retraite et puis de il ya un système
nécessité d' équilibre et c'est ça que
posera jean paul delevoye
le ministre a parlé death d'équilibrer
les équilibres mais c'est l'âge
déquilibre que dit jean paul delevoye
c'est à dire que l'âge de retraite et
bien 62 ans mais un âge d équilibre de
système et donc faut des mécanismes ces
critiques en clair sk pas une forme
d'hypocrisie autour de cet âge des ti
libre ce qui finalement elles partiront
à 62 ans il n'y a qu'une bague au 10 mai
avec une décote mais on verra ce que va
proposer pour seul point qu on veut
enlever on verra ce que je propose jean
paul delevoye il ya plusieurs choses il
ya l'équilibré du système et la
convergence des systèmes pour la justice
donc tout ça ça fait beaucoup
d'équations a rempli en même temps je
relevais pas forcément mais il a
toujours dit qu'il y avait un âge pivot
qui était plutôt à 64 ans excusez moi je
n'y vois à 64 ans avec l'homme décédé
qui vibre avec un bonus malus
c'est ce qu'il a dit donc on va regarder
mais jean paul delevoye va rendre un
rapport
ce n'est pas un texte de loi qui va
fournir et donc après le gouvernement
rendra ses arbitrages en temps et
apparemment vous voulez me permettez
qu'on ne met pas la charrue avant les
boeufs conditionnelle vous avez dit on
va se donner un petit peu de temps ce
que vous aviez
à roger karoutchi juste avant ça veut
dire quoi que ça pourra être quand même
présenté en conseil des ministres avant
la fin 2019 ou pas la révision
constitutionnelle qui a besoin encore
d'un dialogue parce qu'on voit bien ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure que en
particulier sur la représentation le
degré de représentation des territoires
est par ailleurs la réduction d'une
parlementaire on n'est pas tout à faut
que les rial
il ya le moment de renouvellement du
sénat en une fois ou deux fois et puis
de la question de la représentation
territoriale il faut qu'on poursuive le
débat je pense que à partir du moment où
nous tomberions d'accord sur quelque
chose où on peut aller au débat
parlementaire à ce moment là le texte
déposé mais ya pas lieu pour l'instant
dans l'urgence comme vous le voyez on a
parlé de trois textes bioéthique
économie circulaire ils gaspillaient la
lutte contre le gaspillage le texte sur
les collectivités plus le budget ça peut
déjà occupé un peu l'automne alors
justement le texte sur les collectivités
texte sur le statut de l'élu
l'engagement et proximité qui doit être
présentée par sébastien lecornu dans les
prochains jours le but c'est de tenter
d'enrayer la crise de vocations chez les
mères à la proche des municipales est-ce
que l'exécutif n'est quand même pas un
peu responsable de ce découragement des
mères dont la crise des vocations c'est
un phénomène non je vous rappelle que
dans les élections de 2014 on a eu des
tas d'articles expliquant qu elles mêmes
des communes qui a eu du mal à trouver
des candidats disent qu'ils 26 communes
je crois qu'en fait c'était 2014 s'était
pas de mickey 2021 ou 2020 bon donc il
faut par ailleurs on voit souvent une
crise de vocation à ce stade là puis
après les maires réfléchissant se disent
on va y aller je pense que la crise des
vocations elle est pas lié à ce que fait
le gouvernement elle est liée à ce qui
s'est passé pendant des années c'est la
dépossession qu'ont eue les élus en
particulier les élus municipaux pour
gérer leur territoire les grandes moi je
suis un grand défenseur des
intercommunalités je pense qu'elles sont
très utiles dans le paysage pour faire
la coopération et pour porter des
projets ambitieux dans le territoire
succar venas pourra en parler mieux que
moi parce qu'il a voté une loi qui
visait à élargir très profondément les
périmètres des intercommunalités à
sous-représentés au fond les communes
les plus petites et avec des maires qui
ont l'impression qu'ils viennent en gros
vous voir regarder passer les trains
à chaque conseil communautaire qui ne
sont plus impliqués et donc le sentiment
de dépossession du pouvoir municipal
parce qu'on est dans des trop grandes
intercommunalités il décourage les uns
et les autres et puis deux fois c'est
françois hollande est là la nôtre qui
est responsable c'est aller je pas aussi
caricatural que d'autres mans
c'est un long processus de découragement
qui s'est mise à l'heure avec les élus
pendant vingt ans on a déshabillé tous
les services publics locaux et qu'on a
fait disparaître l'état dans les
territoires quand on a fait des
intercommunalités où plus personne ne
comprend rien compte tenu de leur taille
ou des compétences qui sont treize ans
je vais très quand on a fait ça aussi
c'est votre prédécesseur qu'il a fait on
fait baisser de 13 milliards les
dotations aux collectivités
reconnaissons que ça peut à finir par
agacer et décourager les maires moi j'ai
été maire pendant dix ans je sais à quoi
ça ressemble et je reconnais que faut
beaucoup de volonté pour un maire pour
essayer de se dépatouiller de toutes ces
complexités administratives qui ont été
posées sur la table et donc c'est un
texte que porte et bastien le corps nu
qui vise à simplifier un certain nombre
de choses à permettre un peu de
renforcer la démocratie au sein de ces
ensembles aidé à encourager l'engagement
dans les municipalités on a besoin de
gens qui s'engagent plus facile encore
les entrées de ceux qui s'engagent
d'ailleurs est ce que vous êtes en 2020
pour les municipales je suis resté
conseiller municipal de marchenoir
commune de 700 habitants donc ça
nécessite pas une grande investiture
sonné une décision six mois avant gagne
campagne une campagne qui dure sept mois
on verra en tout cas oui j'ai plutôt
envie de rester élue municipale élus
communautaires
d'abord parce que ça permet de
régulièrement et j'essaie de
m'astreindre à aller au conseil
communautaire ou conseils municipaux
madame et fonction d'être en contact
avec les réalités de regarder aussi
d'être en prise avec le réel est de
regarder ce qui se passe entre ce que
nous disons ce que nous essayons de
faire et comment ça se traduit
localement et donc je pense que c'est
une c'est quelque chose d'assez utile et
donc de clariant quand vous avez été
maire élargir la question des municipal
est-ce que vous pensez que tous les
ministres notamment ceux issus de la
société civile doivent être candidats
sur des listes pour être en prison mais
pas dans des joutes casse comme ça en
disant on peut être un très bon ministre
preuve en est d'ailleurs certains sont
sans doute couper du rite et non non on
peut être un très bon ministre
sans être en est un élu local enfin je
veux dire c'est une littérature que de
moi j'ai connu aussi des élus locaux de
très grandes villes qui étaient un peu
déconnecté des réalités
oui ce que je veux dire enfin besoin
d'être élu d'une grande ville pour être
proche des gens et pas besoin de pas
être évident une grande vitesse grandes
villes bordeaux par exemple comment va
soutenir thomas cazenave alors que vous
êtes pouvons dans la majorité sortante
là où et nicolas florian qui est le
successeur d'alain juppé qu'est ce que
vous allez faire avant écoutez nous
sommes dans la continuité d'un accord et
d'un dialogue qu'on a eu à l'époque
à l'époque tout le monde ne voulait pas
forcément nous parler en particulier à
droite avec le mors le maire de bordeaux
de l'époque est alain juppé son
successeur et nicolas florian moi je
pense qu'il faut qu'on accepte aussi
dans les affaires municipales que des
gens puissent avoir une histoire comment
vous justifiez quand vous êtes en accord
avec tel municipalité depuis 15 ans du
jour au lendemain de sortir de cet
accord moi je ne sais pas faire de la
politique comme ça je vous dis aussi
franchement que ça parce que d'abord
c'est des rapports humains et de quand
vous avez assez des services cette
alliance avec avec la république
regardons au cas par cas mais il me
semble qu'à bordeaux nous avions un
accord
est-ce que nous avons voté contre les
budgets qui était présenté par le maire
de bordeaux est ce que nous n'avons pas
été associés à la politique municipale
est ce que nous avons de mauvais
rapports avec la municipalité bordelaise
je coche les casses trois fois non
j'explique comment que je veux partir
comment les électeurs bordelais qui nous
ont fait confiance à nous mais la
candidature d'un casque et les doubles
candidatures concurrentes aussi c'est ça
la question
c'est illogique avec vous même mais et
si vous êtes logique qu'en double
candidature concurrente non mais
pardonnez moi de vous dire que je
comprends en même temps que thomas
cazenave les équipes de la république en
marche et envie de faire entendre leur
voix puisque n'était pas dans cette
alliance là on peut les règles générales
peuvent souffrir des exceptions que
j'essaie de vous expliquer aussi
tranquillement et humainement que c'est
un accord et politiquement que ça parce
que que quand vous allez devant les
citoyens glisse a fait 15 ans que je
suis en alliance avec cette équipe là et
j'ai décidé sans aucun motif autre que
ça a changé
je sors de cette alliance jeu c'est
compliqué devant les citoyens et en même
temps je comprends très bien que thomas
cazenave dont on dit que c'est un très
bon profil aient envie de se lancer dans
la course aux municipales à bordeaux ait
envie de faire entendre sa voix et dijon
pareil pour disposer d'un allié au parti
socialiste
avant ce rêve je vois les mêmes règles
je connais un peu la carte électorale
quand vous le savez je veux bien qu'on
égrène toutes les villes on verra ville
par ville
l'idée c'est que nous ayons dans le
maximum de gilles un dialogue un
dialogue d'alliance avec la république
en marche
et puis un deuxième chose qu'il faudra
au cas laquelle il faudra faire
attention c'est que nous soyons en
capacité de rassembler au-delà d'un
marché du modem je pense que nous
ferions défaut à notre adn collectif de
2017 qui était celui d'une stratégie du
dépassement et de l'élargissement si
nous disions seul au monde
face à venus elle s'appelait un certain
nombre de gens à droite ou à gauche
d'ailleurs dans les investitures yade et
d'aujourd'hui y compris en cas d un
certain nombre de gens qui viennent de
la droite des gens qui viennent plutôt
de la droite de la gauche et des gens
pardonnez moi qui viennent même du
centre c'est ça qu'il faut
ils veulent assassiner le verbe faire la
liste de tous les temps
dervis att vous soutenez guerre perdriau
élèves alors la rose mais moi toutes ces
complications possibles de travail ont
une fatigue questions et les réponses
laissez moi finir simplement dix ans
nous avons nos propres processus on
désignera des chefs de file des thèmes
des têtes de liste et qu'on investira
l'idée c'est la philosophie c'est
d'essayer de se rassembler avec en
marche et décidé de continuer à lire la
suite interview qu'il n'avait pas fallu
rock apparaissent qu'il n'aurait pas
fallu attendre pour la république en
marche qui a présenté vous le disiez
aujourd'hui une deuxième vague ce n'est
pas trop tôt je ne vois pas donner des
oukases mais je pense à la république en
marche et ils sont dans le calendrier
qu'ils choisissent
et nous nous avons un calendrier que
nous choisissons tranquillement qui
n'est pas le vôtre mais ça aide pas au
dialogue ils ont rassemblé en dessous
mal quand même stanislas guérini avait
l'impression de bien traiter d'être un
allié toujours choyé par la république
employés je pense qu'on est un allié en
tout cas respecté respecte je pense
qu'on est un allié respecter à tout en
assurant ils auront toujours besoin de
vous c'est pas la question du besoin
vous n'êtes pas respecté que parce qu'on
a besoin de vous ah c'est qu'au fond
d'attentes à respecter c'est vrai mais
je pense que pour être respecté il faut
porter quelque chose d'un message
politique qui soit suffisamment fort pas
seulement parce qu on appelait ça vous
fait pas peur un agir de gauche là qui
est en train de se constituer
je pense en tout cas qu'il faut veiller
à ne pas renvoyer à ce qui était le
modèle avant 2017 s'il faut faire un
agir de gauche à n'agir de droite et
puis un agir du centre on agir
écologistes aussi je veux dire je ne
pense pas qu'il faille raisonner comme
ça la stratégie du déplacement est une
stratégie qu'il faut pas se remettre sur
respectez vous l'avez dit marc fesneau
merci beaucoup aussi à vous d'abord est
avec nous aujourd'hui merci madame
bonsoir à tous et la semaine prochaine
avec jacqueline gourault votre collègue
que vous soyez l'otan richir et en force
la loire et le centre égal